The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LORNA GIBSON: All right.
So last time we were talking
about tissue engineering
scaffolds.
And what we're going
to talk about today
still has to do with tissue
engineering scaffolds,
but we're going to look at it
from a different perspective.
So last time we
were looking more
at sort of a
clinical perspective,
and looking at those
osteochondral scaffolds
for repairing small
defects in cartilage.
And today what we're
going to talk about
are how cells-- how
biological cells,
interact with the scaffolds.
And there's various
kinds of interactions.
So we're going to go
through a bunch of these.
So the first one I'm
going to talk about
is degradation of the scaffolds.
Then we'll talk about
the cell attachment.
Cell morphology-- so the shape
of the pores in the scaffold
can affect the way the
biological cells-- what
shape they have.
Biological cells could
also contract the scaffold
and apply mechanical forces.
So we're going to
talk about that.
The stiffness of the
scaffold and the pore size
can affect the speed
of cell migration.
And the stiffness
of the scaffold
can affect the differentiation
of cells, so from one cell type
to another.
So I thought today
I'd talk about that.
This probably won't
take the whole hour.
The next topic is on
energy absorption in foams.
And so we'll probably start that
towards the end of the lecture.
OK.
So the idea here is
that we're looking
at how scaffolds are
being used, really,
to provide a 3D
environment to characterize
the behavior of cells.
And in particular,
how the cells interact
with their environment.
So let's write that down.
So how the cell behavior is
affected by the substrate
it's on.
OK.
So the first thing we're
going to talk about
is scaffold degradation.
And if you think of the
native extracellular matrix,
the cells secrete enzymes
which resorb that matrix
and then they also
deposit new matrix.
So it was kind of
like what we were
talking about with the bone.
The bone is always being
resorbed and deposited.
And if there's a balance
between that those two,
then the density of the
bone stays the same.
And if one of the rates
gets out of whack,
then you get osteoporosis
and you lose bone mass.
So the idea is that in just the
native extracellular matrix,
the cells are producing enzymes
that degrade the scaffold.
And those enzymes are also
going to degrade the tissue
engineering scaffolds as well.
And you want to
be able to control
the rate of degradation,
versus the rate
at which the native
extracellular
matrix gets deposited.
Excuse me, sorry.
So you can kind of imagine
if the tissue engineering
scaffold did not
resorb quickly enough,
you'd have scaffold there.
And the cells would
be trying to put down
their own extracellular
matrix, and there
wouldn't be a place to put it.
And if it resorbs too
quickly, then the cells
don't have something
to attach to.
So there has to be a balance
between the rate at which
the enzymes are resorbing the
tissue engineering scaffold,
versus the rate at which
the cells are depositing
their own extracellular matrix.
So in the native
extracellular matrix,
the enzymes produced
by the cells
are resorbing the
extracellular matrix.
And then the cells are
also synthesizing so they
synthesize ECM to replace it.
So the cells are also going to
degrade the tissue engineering
scaffold that you put in.
And the length of time that
the scaffold is insoluble,
or so that it remains
in the body as a solid,
is called the residence time.
And so then we require
the scaffold degradation
to occur over a time that
balances with the new ECM
synthesis.
And so the scaffold
residence time
must be about equal
to the time required
to make new native
extracellular matrix.
So the degradation rate
depends on the composition
of the scaffold, on how
much cross linking there is,
and on the relative density.
Obviously, the more
scaffold there is,
the longer it's going
to take to degrade it.
And with synthetic polymers you
can vary the molecular weight
of the polymer.
And sometimes if
you have copolymers,
one may degrade
faster than the other.
And you can control the balance
of how much of each copolymer
you have.
And for natural
proteins, like collagen,
you can control the
amount of cross linking.
So you can do the cross
linking by various techniques.
That's what's called
physical methods.
There's something called
dehydrothermal treatment, where
you heat the collagen up to
105 degrees C in a vacuum,
in a dry environment.
And that eliminates water and
causes more cross linking.
There's a UV treatment,
ultraviolet light treatment,
you can use.
And there's also chemical
cross linkers you can use.
So there's different
chemical methods you can also
use to cross link the collagen.
OK.
So the next thing I wanted to
talk about was cell adhesion.
And let's just wait a minute
for people to catch up.
Are we just about there?
So this next slide shows
a sort of schematic
of how a cell would
adhere to a substrate.
So down at the bottom here,
all these little squiggly lines
are representing the
extracellular matrix
in the native tissue.
Or you can think of it as
a, say, a collagen scaffold.
But here we have the ECM.
And this little blob
here is our cell.
This is the nucleus of the cell
here, the little green blob
in the middle.
And the cell is
attached to the ECM
through something called
focal adhesion points.
And this schematic here is a
blow up of that focal adhesion.
And at the focal
adhesion there's
proteins called integrins.
And integrins pass
across the cell membrane.
So the idea is the
integrins attach to ligands
on the extracellular matrix.
And then they also attached
to the sub membrane plaque
within the cell.
And then that plaque attaches
to the side of skeleton.
Things like actin
filaments within the cell.
So this is what
attaches the cell
as a whole to the
extracellular matrix,
is these focal
adhesion sites here.
And different kinds of
cell behaviors-- obviously,
things like cell
attachment, but also
migration, are affected
by those focal adhesions there.
So we have that the cells attach
to the ECM at focal adhesions.
And sometimes you see those
referred to just as FA.
And at the adhesion point
the cell has integrins.
And the integrins are
transmembrane proteins,
so they go across the membrane.
And they bind to
like ends on the ECM.
And then the other
end of the integrin
is attached to the submembrane
plaque within the cell.
And then that connects
to the cytoskeleton.
And then different kinds
of cell behaviors-- so
for example, things
like adhesion,
and proliferation,
and migration.
And that cell contraction,
we're going to talk more
about that in a minute.
They all depend in part on
this adhesion between the cells
and the extracellular matrix.
And the biological activity
depends on how many
binding sites there are.
So if you think of the
extracellular matrix,
it's got these
ligands and it depends
on the density of binding
sites, how much interaction
you can get.
So things like how much
cell attachment you can get,
depends in part on just how
many of these binding sites
you've got for the
cells to attach to.
And that density of
the binding sites
or the density of the ligands
depends on the composition
of the scaffold.
But also on the surface area
per unit volume of the scaffold.
So if you think of first,
just the composition,
if you have native proteins,
like collagen, they
have binding sites themselves.
They have native binding sites.
But if you think of
synthetic polymers,
like the resorbable
sutured type of polymers
that we talked about, they
don't have binding sites
and you have to coat the
scaffold with some sort
of adhesive protein.
And then the surface area per
unit volume of the scaffold
is related to the pore size
and the relative density.
Let's call the
specific surface area,
surface area per unit volume.
And if you think of having
some scaffold that's
like an open celled
foam, you can roughly
calculate what the surface
area per unit volume is.
So say each strut
was a cylinder,
then the surface
area of each cylinder
is going to be 2 pi rl.
If each one has a
radius r and a length l.
Say we had n of them, that
would be your surface area.
And the volume of the whole
scaffold, or one cell,
would go as l cubed, the
length of each strut cubed.
So if we just forget about
all the constants here.
Forget about n.
This just goes as r
over l times 1 over l,
and that goes as the relative
density to the 1/2 power
times 1 over the pore size.
So the specific surface area
depends on the relative density
and on the pore size.
And if you have a
tetrakaidecahedron cell,
you can work out exactly
what that relationship is.
It's sort of a model.
And that gives you the
relationship there.
And in this particular
case, I think
the relative density was 0.5%.
And so it's a constant
over the cell size.
So one of the things
we did in my group
was look at how cell
attachment varied
with this specific surface area.
So we seeded cells onto
scaffolds of different pore
sizes.
We kept the relative
density constant
and we changed the pore sizes.
Remember I said, when we make
these scaffolds by freeze
drying we can control
the pore size,
by controlling the
freezing temperature.
And we see that it's just a
linear relationship between how
many cells attach, or the
percentage of the cells
that were seeded that attach,
and the specific surface area.
In here we used MC 3T3 cells.
It's sort of a standard
cell one that you can get.
So Fergal O'Brien was
the post-doc in my group
who did that.
So I'll just say we
find cell attachment is
proportional to the
specific surface area.
OK.
So that's the cell attachment.
So you can see how the
scaffold design is going
to affect how the cells attach.
So there's some relationship
between them there.
Another thing people have
looked at is cell morphology.
And so if you change, the sort
of, orientation of the pores,
how does that change the
orientation of the cells?
So this was a study
done in another group.
So here we have
randomly oriented fibers
that make up the scaffold.
And here they're not
perfectly oriented this way,
but more or less.
And then these are
cells that have
been seeded onto them, so
that the green staining is
the cells.
And you can see if the
scaffold is random,
the cells themselves line
up with that fiber structure
and become more or less random.
And if the scaffold
has fibers that
are aligned, then
the cells, they also
line up and be aligned.
So the morphology
of the cells can
be affected by the orientation
of the scaffold pores.
Also the cell morphology
can be affected
by the stiffness of the cells.
Or the stiffness
of the substrate.
So this is a substrate.
Here this was a
PEG-fibrinogen hydrogel.
And they varied the cross
linking of this hydrogel.
So they got different
modularly for the hydrogel.
So these numbers here, are
all the stiffness of the four
different hydrogels.
And you can see the
cell morphology changes
from being a spread out thing
on the least stiff substrate,
to being just a little
spherical or circular blob
on the most stiff substrate.
So the cells respond
to the substrate.
And so how the cells
behave, depends
in part on their environment.
So I wanted to also talk
about womb contraction.
And talk about how cells
contract scaffolds as well.
So one of the things
people have found
when they look at say, skin
and regeneration of skin--
so say you had
somebody with a burn
and the surgeons will
clean the burnt out.
And then what will
happen as it heals,
is scar tissue will form.
And the scar tissue
forms in conjunction
with the wound contracting.
So cells will actually
migrate into the wound bed
and they'll pull the
edges of the wound
together to try to
close the wound.
And they won't
close it completely,
but they'll partially close it.
And that's called
wound contraction.
And that is thought to be
associated with the formation
of scar tissue.
So the cells can actually
apply mechanical loads.
And they can contract the wound.
And one of the things that
Professor Yannas found
was that if you use one of his
collagen and gag scaffolds,
you can inhibit that
wound contraction.
And if you can prevent the wound
contraction from occurring,
you also prevent the
formation of the scar tissue.
And that allows
normal dermis to form.
So you get normal skin.
So this photograph
here is of somebody
who had burns over
their entire torso.
And they put this tissue
injury scaffold on this part
at the bottom, but not
on that part at the top.
And you can see these lines
here are contracture lines
from the scar formation.
And you can see this skin down
here is relatively normal.
And in fact, when people look
at the histology of the skin
the forms using
these scaffolds, they
find that it is pretty much
the same as normal dermis.
It doesn't have sweat glands and
it doesn't have hair follicles.
So you can't sweat from that
skin and you don't grow hair.
But apart from that, it's
more or less normal dermis.
So this observation
that if you can inhibit
the womb contraction, you
can prevent scar formation
and you can get
normal dermis to form.
That's led to some
interest in just
seeing how is it that the cells
do this contract l process.
I think hitting the thing
and my battery is dead.
So one of the things
people have done,
is they've just taken what's
called, free floating scaffold.
They've just taken
little disks of scaffold
and put it in a cell culture
medium in a Petri dish.
And they find that if you
put, say fiberblast on it,
the fiberblast will
contract that scaffold.
And people have
measured how much
the diameter of the
scaffold changes.
And so they've kind of
measured this contraction
just by-- it's almost
like measuring a strain.
And what we wanted
to do is we wanted
to try to measure the
forces that were involved.
So we first developed something
called a cell force monitor,
and I'll show you that.
And then we tried to calculate
how much an individual cell
could apply in
terms of the force.
So we used this scaffold here.
This is the same collagen GAG
scaffold I showed you before.
And here's the
cell force monitor.
So that's just a
schematic of holding
a piece of the scaffold
between two clamps.
So here it is in elevation view.
And then I'll just build
the whole thing up,
so you can see how it works.
So it's on a base plate.
It's attached to a horizontal
stage that's adjustable.
Then there's a very
thin beam here.
So this is another
adjustable stage here,
and this very thin beam here.
And that's attached to
one end of this clamp.
And here's the matrix.
And this is attached to this
other adjustable stage here.
And then when we have
a proximity sensor-- so
what's going to happen is,
this is fixed over here.
The scaffold is
going to contract
with the cells applying
these contract l forces.
This beam here is going to
bend and the proximity sensor
is going to tell us
how much it's bent.
So we can measure
how much that's bent.
If we know how much that's
bent, and we calibrate the beam,
we can figure out the
force in the beam.
OK.
So we can figure out how much is
the total force that the cells
are contracting with.
And then this just is a
little silicone well with
some culture medium.
So that's the whole setup there.
Toby Fryman was a student
who did that, who's
married to Professor Van Vliet.
And I have a very big soft
spot for both of them.
So anyway, that's the set up.
And the thing that Toby
measured was the force,
by measuring how much
that beam deflected.
And he measured the
force over time.
And he found that if he put say,
a certain number of fiberblasts
onto the scaffold, the force
would increase and then reach
an asymptotic point.
And you could describe these
curves by this equation here.
Here's the asymptotic force.
And it's a 1 minus exponential
of minus time over a time
constant tao.
And then this number here
is the number of fiberblast
that were attached at 22 hours.
So he ran these
tests for 22 hours.
And when he was
finished, he could
count the number of cells that
were attached in the scaffolds.
So you would just wash off any
cells that weren't attached
and you can do accounting
of how many cells are left.
And one of the
things that he found
was that if you plot that
asymptotic force-- if you plot
through this force over here,
against the number of cells
that were attached, you just
get a linear relationship.
And the slope of that is
roughly the force per cell.
And that's about
one nano neutron.
Now this is a little deceptive
because not all the cells
are contracting.
And not all the cells are
lined up in one direction.
So there are cells in
different orientations.
But just as an
order of magnitude
the cells are applying something
like one minute per cell.
So that's the effect
of the cell number.
Another thing he
did was he looked
at what happens if you change
the stiffness of that beam if.
You make that beam in the
device different stiffnesses,
how do the cells react.
And so the stiffness here are
the stiffness of the system.
So there's 0.7 newtons
per meter up to ten,
so it's a factor of a
little over ten difference.
And you can see the
displacement per cell changes.
The stiffer the system is the
less the cells can displace it.
But if you then plot
the force per cell,
you find that the force
per cell is about the same.
So you develop about
the same force.
So that suggests the cells
are capable of applying
a certain amount of force,
and not any more force.
No larger force.
So he did that.
Then we were interested in
what was the mechanism of this.
How were the cells
applying this force?
Because I was kind of
surprised to find out the cells
even could apply forces.
So we were interested
in understanding
the mechanism of this.
And one of the things we knew
that we didn't quite figure out
how this all worked
together was,
we knew that the
cells elongated.
If you just take a substrate,
like even just a 2d substrate,
and you put cells on it they'll
be rounded to start out with.
And over time, over a few
hours, they'll spread.
And that's pretty standard.
Many types of
cells will do that.
So we knew the cells were
starting off as rounded
and they were spreading.
So the cells are getting
longer, but our whole scaffolds
getting shorter.
And so it wasn't obvious how
was the cells going longer,
but the scaffold's
getting shorter.
And so the next thing
we thought we would do
is just watch the cells
and see what they did.
And so we measured the
aspect ratio of the cells
at different time points.
And we did this by
just impregnating
the scaffold in the
cells at different time
points with a resin,
and then using a stain,
and then using digital
image analysis.
So what we found was that
the fiber of the fiberglass
morphology looked like this.
So the long thready
things of the scaffold,
and these little blobs here are
the fiberblast of the cells.
So here at time 0 you
can see-- like I said,
the cells are pretty rounded
they're not very spread out.
Here at eight hours
you can see-- here's
a cell that's gotten longer.
Here's another one.
This guy here is still
rounded, it's not doing much.
22 hours, again, some of the
cells are quite elongated.
Some of them are still
not that elongated.
So they don't all become active.
But one of the
things we noticed,
if you look at this image
here, you can see these cells
are attached at one end,
and at the other end.
But they're not
attached in the middle.
There's sort of a gap between
the cell and the strut.
And this is another
example here.
Here's a cell here, and this
is the collagen GAG strut
that it's attached to.
And you can see it's
attached to the two ends,
but not in the middle.
And this starts
to explain how it
is that the cells are elongating
but the scaffolds getting
shorter.
It's that the cells are
just attached at two ends.
And the cells are
moving along a strut
and they're attached
to the two ends.
And if you think of
the cells attached
through those focal
adhesion points,
they're applying
tension to the cell.
And the actin filaments in
the cell are in tension.
Obviously, filaments
can't be in compression.
They're only going
to be in tension.
And what happens is that puts
the stress into compression.
And if the struts in
compression, at some point
it's going to buckle.
And you can see this
strut here has basically
buckled under that cell.
And so if the cells
are getting longer,
and they're buckling
the struts, then that's
going to shorten the struts
and the whole scaffold
is going to get shorter.
And so then Toby plotted the
aspect ratio of the cell,
so that is a measure of their
elongation against the time.
And again, he found
one of these curves
with the same kind
of form as the curve
for the forced development.
And he found the
time constant here
for the change in the aspect
ratio was about five hours.
And for the development of the
force it was about 5.7 hours.
So the time constant for
the elongation of the cells,
more or less matches
up with a time
constant for
developing the force.
So that's what that says.
And that suggests there's a
link between the elongation
of the cell population and
the macroscopic contraction
of the population.
So then we wanted to
take it one step further.
And we wanted to look at what
the cells were doing live.
Like as they were doing it.
So Toby devised this little
schematic thing here.
So he had just an
optical microscope.
He had a microscope slide with
a fairly thick well in it,
so that we could put
culture medium in the well.
We put a cell seeded
matrix in here.
And he had a heated stage here.
And then he took little videos
of what the cells were doing.
And this required some patience
because as you could see
not all the cells did anything.
Some of them just sat
there and did nothing.
So he would set this up for
a day, and watch a cell,
and it would do nothing.
And then he would have
to find another cell.
But he did find
some cells that were
responsible for the contraction.
And that was it
was kind of neat.
So here's the scaffold again.
All these little bits
here are the scaffold.
This is a strut of the scaffold.
And this is a fiberblast
parked on the scaffold.
And this has a
little video here.
And you can see what's
happening is the strut here
is starting to buckle.
And you can see
these two sides here,
those two things are
coming closer together.
So they originally
were this piece here,
and that piece there.
And now they're at
that point there.
And then if I let it
go a little bit longer,
it continues to do that process.
And then the final thing--
this kind of smushed up mess
here is these two things having
me brought completely together.
And this strut here is
some strut down over here.
So you can see how the cells
are elongating and causing
contraction of the scaffold.
Here's a series of stills taken
from another video that he did.
So this sort of square
thing is the scaffold.
So b is the scaffold.
And a, this little blob
here, is the fiberblast.
And you can see, even from
this image to this one,
you can see that the
fiberblast has spread a little.
Do you see how it's kind of
oozed out along the scaffold
there.
And eventually it
attaches over here.
And you can see
that it's buckled
this strut underneath it.
And here it's a little
bit more deformed.
It then grabs on
down here somewhere
and deforms it even more.
So you can see
that's more deformed.
And then Toby put alcohol
on the whole thing,
which kills the cells
and the cell let's go.
And you can see you recover
some of the deformation.
You don't recover all of it,
but you recover some of it.
This was another example.
And this was kind
of interesting.
Here there was a
scaffold junction
where there were three
struts that came together,
a little bit like a strut.
And there was a little
cell right there.
And you can see
the cell elongates.
You see how this
elongated and its grabbing
on up here somewhere.
But the amount of
force the cell was
kind of pulling with must
have been less than the--
or rather must been
more than the force
of the focal adhesion.
Because what happens
was eventually
the focal adhesion let go.
And the cell kind of bounces
back and ends up over here.
So the cell was
kind of snapped back
on to the other focal
adhesion over here.
And here it's rounded again.
And here it elongates again.
And then this focal
adhesion lets go
and now it's moved
back over to there.
So these struts
here are so stiff.
They're much stiffer,
I think, partly
because they're triangulated.
And it looks like they're just
shorter and a lot thicker.
The cell isn't being
able to deform those.
But it's elongating and then
focal adhesion was letting go.
So this is a little schematic
of what we thinks going on.
So the cell starts out--
it's some elongation here.
It's attached at that point.
It's attached at
that point there.
And the cell is getting longer.
And if you think about it as
the cell's getting longer--
if you think about the
Euler Buckling formula,
the buckling load goes
as 1 over l squared.
So the longer the
length of this piece
of the strut of the scaffold
underneath the cell is,
the smaller the load it takes
to actually cause it to buckle.
So at some point it
buckles like this.
And this is just a
little force diagram.
So the actin fibers
are in tension
and the matrix strut
is in compression.
Sometimes we saw some bending.
So you could see if a cell was
spanning between two struts,
you could get the cell
bending the struts as well.
That was another possibility.
And so we think that
the cell elongation
was related to the contraction.
The time constants for the two
things were almost the same.
And as the cell elongates
there's a gap between the cell
and the matrix on
the central portion.
And then the cell is adhered at
the periphery of the adhesion
points.
And then the tensile
forces in these act.
And filaments inside the
cell induce compression
in the strut, and
that causes buckling.
And then Toby graduated.
And then I got another
student, Brendan.
And Brendan saw what
Toby did and he wanted
to do a little more with that.
Brandon was also involved
that osteochondral project
that I talked about last time.
And Brendan this other thing
as well for his project.
So he wanted to measure the
force of an individual cell.
So when we had that
cell force monitor,
that was the total force of
all the cells in that one
direction.
But Brendan wanted to
know if he could measure
the force of a single cell.
And now that we knew that the
contractal process was related
to buckling, We thought,
well, we could just
use Euler's formula.
If we knew what the
modulus of the solid
was, and we knew what the
dimensions of the struts were.
So that would allow us to
calculate the contractile force
of a single fiberblast.
So I think I've shown
you this thing here.
So Brendan was the one
who did these experiments.
He cut a single strut
out of the scaffold.
And the single strut is
about 100 microns long.
He used a microscope to do this.
He then glued it
onto a glass slide
and he used the atomic
force microscope probe
to bend the strut like
a cantilever beam.
And he measured this
displacement here.
And from that he could back out
what the modulus of the solid
was.
He did these tests
in the dry state.
But we could extrapolate
to the wet state
from looking at the behavior
of the whole scaffold.
So he had a modulus for
the wet scaffold solid.
And then this is our formula
for Euler buckling here.
So that's just the
standard formula.
I had a student from
civil engineering, who
looked at hydrostatic loading
of a tetrakaidecahedral cell
and he looked at buckling.
If you had a
tetrakaidecahedral cell and you
load it in all three directions.
He looked at the buckling.
And he had calculated that
the n constraint factor--
the n squared was point 0.34.
So we have some idea of what
that n squared value should be.
Although it's somewhat
of an estimate.
I had a UROP student
who took Toby's images
and measured the
dimensions of the struts.
So he measured the diameter and
the thickness of the struts.
And from that, we just
plugged everything
into the Euler formula.
And we found that the
average single cell
force is somewhere between
about 11 and 41 nano neutron.
It was something like
26 nano neutrons.
So it would make sense that
it's more than the one nano
neutron per cell because not
all of those cells were active
and they weren't all going
in the same direction.
So Brendan Harley and Matt Wong
did that part of the project.
OK.
So that's the contraction.
Are we good with contraction?
So it's kind of interesting
that cells will contract
and we can measure some forces.
So the next type of
interaction between the cells
and the scaffolds that
I wanted to talk about
is cell migration.
And these are some studies
from the literature.
These are two different studies.
But the top one here, they've
measured migration rate
as a function of
the cross linking
treatment of a scaffold.
And the decreasing
stiffness goes this way.
And so they're seeing that
the speed of migration-- this
is in millimeters per day.
Cells don't move too quickly.
They go millimeters per day.
But you can see that the
migration speed, the speed
at which the cells
can move, depends
on the stiffness of the scaffold
that they're attached to.
And in this study on the
bottom here, what they did was
they had just a
flat 2d substrate.
Just a flat polymer.
And what they did was they cross
linked one part of the polymer
more than the other
part of polymer.
So over here, this was
the less cross linked.
That was the soft part.
And this was the more
highly cross linked.
This was the stiffer part.
And they found that if they
put a cell on the soft part
it would migrate
onto the stiff part.
But if they put a cell
on the stiff part,
it would start going this
way towards the soft part.
But when it got to
the interface it
would just spread out
along the interface.
And it wouldn't go
into the soft part.
So the cells were
somehow sensing
the stiffness of the substrate.
And for some reason, I don't
know what, but for some reason
these particular
cells seem to prefer
being on the stiff substrate.
So this is just really
showing that there's
some interaction between the
substrate stiffness and the way
the cells are behaving
and migrating.
And then Brendan also
wanted to study this.
And he got some of the
collagen GAG scaffold.
He made some of the scaffold.
And he stained that with a
stain that made it turn red.
So these lines here are all
red struts in the scaffold.
And then he put fiberblasts
on to the scaffold
and stained them green.
So all these little blobs here
that are green are the cells.
And then he used
confocal microscopy.
And the confocal
microscopy allowed
him to look at a certain
volume of the scaffold.
And he had some
software that would
track the centroid
of each cell as it
moved through the scaffold.
And so he had a thing
he called spot tracking.
So each of these little spheres
here corresponds to a cell.
And the white box is
the volume of material
that you could see
in the scaffold.
And this color scale here
really corresponds to time.
So I've forgotten which round.
I think blue is the
original time 0,
and then red is
maybe five seconds,
and yellow was 10 seconds.
The different colors
correspond to different times.
So he could track
the path of each cell
and also what the position
was at different time points.
So he knew what the position
And obviously from
that, he could
get the speed of the scaffold.
And he did these
experiments on scaffolds
of different stiffnesses, as
well as, different pore size.
And here you can
see the cell speed.
He's measuring it in
microns per hour now.
The cell speed
increases at first
and then decreases with
the strut stiffness.
So we don't know
exactly why this is.
But there is an effect between
the stiffness of the scaffold
and the migration speed.
And another thing
he did was he looked
at how the cell speed
varies with the pore size.
And as the pore size gets
smaller, the speed goes up.
And we're not entirely
sure why that is.
But I think that might be
related to this binding site
thing too.
As the pore size goes down,
the number of binding sites
is going to go up.
And if you think of
the cells migrating
by having these adhesion sites,
and the adhesion sites are just
at the ends of the cells, and
the cells kind of putting out
a little extension, and then
looking for somewhere else
it can bind.
The more binding
sites there are,
the faster it's going
to find a binding site.
And the faster, I think,
it's going to move on.
So I think that the cell speed
depends on pore size, at least
in part because of the
increase in the binding sites
with smaller pore sizes.
So pore size and the migration.
And then the last thing
I wanted to talk about
was cell differentiation.
And this is a study
study by Engler.
And one of the things he found
was he put mesenchymal stem
cells on 2d substrates.
Just flat 2d substrates
of different stiffnesses.
And again, he could control
the stiffness by cross linking.
And what he's showing
up here in the first bit
is that he's looking at
the stiffness of tissues
of different kinds.
So here's brain type tissue.
Something like one kilo pascal.
Muscle might be something
like 10 kilo pascal.
And collagenous
bone-- this is sort
of the osteoid that is
the precursor of bone, not
the bone itself.
Is about 100 kilo pascals.
And what he did was he
put these mesenchymal
stem cells-- so here's his
cell onto his substrate.
And he varied the
stiffness of the substrate.
And then he looked at
the shape of the cells.
So here's the least
stiff substrate,
so between point 1
and 1 kilo pascals.
And here's 4 hours,
24 hours, 96 hours.
And these cells
formed long processes
extending beyond the cell body.
And they looked kind
of like neurons.
So they he called
those neuron like.
Then there's an intermediate
stiffness of substrate here.
And these cells became
even more elongated.
And became something like a
muscle cell, myoblast like.
And then cells that were
put onto a substrate that
was between about 25
and 40 kilo pascals,
they developed a shape that was
something like an osteoblast,
like a bone cell.
So one of the things
he was looking at here,
was how the stiffness
of the substrate
affected how a stem
cell might differentiate
into different cell types.
And another thing that he did
was he looked at different cell
markers.
And he found that the
cells were expressing
markers that were corresponding
to the types of tissue.
So I couldn't tell you the
names of all these things
and what they are.
But I think the red
here is expressing
more of a particular marker.
And I think these wounds
were related to nerve tissue.
These wounds here, were
related more to muscle tissue.
And these wounds here were
related more to bone tissue.
So the things the cells
were expressing also
seemed to correspond to the
different types of tissue
that they were corresponding to.
So I'm just going to
end this part by going
through a little summary here.
So what I've tried
to show you today
is different types
of cell behavior
that are affected
by the scaffold.
And they're affected by
things like the number
of binding sites,
by the pore size,
by the stiffness
of the scaffold.
So we started with
a cell attachment.
We saw that the cell
attachment increases linearly
with a specific surface area.
We saw that the cell morphology
depends on the orientation
of the pores.
And that kind of
makes sense, they
got to line up with the pores.
We talked about the
contraction behaviors.
So the cells bind at the
periphery, the cells elongate,
and that causes this buckling.
And you can calculate
the buckling forces.
It's around 10 to
40 nano neutrons.
We looked at the
cell migration speed.
That increases with the
stiffness of 1D fibers.
And we looked at cell migration
in the collagen gag scaffolds.
So that depends on the
stiffness of the pore size.
And then there was
this final study
on the cell differentiation.
So I wasn't going to
write any notes on this
because the slides I think
pretty much explain it.
So I was just going
to put the slides
on the website at the end
after today's lecture.
So are we good with how
cells and the scaffolds
of the environments interact?
Because I think
it's not so obvious
that this actual mechanical
environment makes a difference.
People think of the chemical,
the biochemical environment.
That obviously
affects the cells.
But people don't think
at first that something
like the sort of structure
of the pores, the pore size,
or the orientation of the pores,
or the mechanical properties
are going to affect
how the cells behave.
But in fact, they do.
So that's it.
And this is all various
people who worked
with me on these projects.
So it was a lot of fun.
OK.
So hang on a sec here.
What's this all about?
I'm going to get rid of that.
Go away.
Here we go.
OK.
So are we good with
cells and substrates?
Yeah?
OK.
So let's just take
a little moment
and I'll rub the board off.
And then we can
start the next bit.
OK.
So that's the end of the
medical material stuff.
So we talked about the bone.
We talked about the tissue
engineering scaffolds.
And then we talked about the
cell scaffold interactions.
So now we're going to go back
to more engineering topics.
And the next thing I
wanted to talk about
was energy absorption in foams.
So foams are very widely
used for energy absorption
applications, things
like bicycle helmets,
different kinds of helmets.
You buy a new computer, it
comes in foam packaging.
And the reason foams
are used so much
is they're extremely good at
absorbing energy from impact.
And in fact, they're
better than the solid
that they're made from.
So let's just look at this
curve here for a minute.
So here's a stress strain curve
in compression for the foam.
And the material
that it's made from
would have the stiffness
something like this.
It would be much, much
stiffer than the foam.
And if you think about how
much energy you can absorb,
the energy you can
absorb is just the area
under the stress/strain curve.
That's the energy you can absorb
in a given volume of foam.
And so when you're thinking
about these energy absorption
problems, it's not
just that you need
to absorb a certain energy.
You need to absorb it without
exceeding a certain peak
stress.
So whatever it is you're trying
to protect, at some point
it's going to break.
This is what you want to avoid.
You want to avoid it breaking.
So you don't want to
have a stress bigger
than the stress
that's going to break
whatever it is, your computer,
or your head, or whatever.
So say you have a
given peak stress
that you can tolerate here.
And we've normalized things
by the solid modules.
But just say that's
a peak stress here.
The foam is going to absorb
this amount of energy
up here, this whole
little shaded region.
And the solid is going to absorb
that little, teeny weeny bit
in there.
So what you want to do
is absorb the energy
without exceeding a
certain peak stress.
And the foam is always going
to be better than the solid
that it's made from.
There's a couple other things
that make the foams good
because they're more or less
isotropic, maybe not perfectly.
But roughly, they have the same
properties in all directions.
Sometimes you don't know
what direction the impact's
going to come from.
And so if you've got
the same properties
in all directions or roughly
the same, that's a good thing.
You also want the protective
thing to be light.
If you're paying for shipping
for your computer or whatever,
the fact that the
packaging is light
makes the shipping easier.
If you have a helmet
for your head,
you don't want some
big heavy thing.
You want something fairly light.
And foams are cheap.
So the fact that they're roughly
isotropic, they're light,
they're cheap, this
all helps as well.
But from a mechanical
point of view,
foams are very good
at absorbing energy.
And so what we're going
to do in the next--
the rest of this lecture
and on Wednesday-- we're
going to see how we can
convert these stress/strain
curves into what are called
energy absorption diagrams.
We're going to look at some
energy absorption diagrams
that we just measure from
the stress/strain curves.
And we're going to look at
how we can predict the energy
absorption diagrams as well.
OK.
So the main idea here is
that the impact protection
has to absorb the
energy from the impact
but without exceeding
a certain peak stress.
So the direction of loading
may not be predictable.
And foams are good because
they're roughly Isotropic.
And they would have the
same energy absorption
capacity from any direction.
And foams are also
light and cheap.
We can say for a given peak
stress the foam is always
going to absorb more energy
than the solid it's made from.
So other things
that make foams good
are that they have a capacity
to undergo large deformations.
And they do that at
roughly constant stress.
So that if you look
at the stress strain
curve for the foam,
you're going to be
able to absorb all
this energy under here.
And these strains that
the foam might go to
might be 0.08 to 0.09, so
huge strains on an engineering
scale.
And then this is your
energy-- would absorb
is that area under the
stress/strain curve.
So I wanted to say something
about strain rates too.
So typically we're
going to be talking
about problems of impact.
And in impact, the strain
rates are typically
on the order of 10 to 100 per
second, something like that.
We're not going to talk
about things like blast.
If you have a blast
loading, then you
have to take inertial
effects into account.
And blasts involves
strain rates,
which are 1,000 to 10,000 per
second, much, much higher.
So we're going to talk
about strain rates that
are about 10 to 100 per second,
maybe a bit more than that.
And for instance,
you can roughly
estimate what one of these
impact rates would be.
So you had something
that you dropped
from a height of 1 meter.
Then the velocity on
impact is just if you just
equate the potential energy
with a kinetic energy.
The velocity and impact is
just the square root of 2gh.
So g's the gravity acceleration.
And h is the height.
So that's the square root
of 2 plus 9.81 meters
per second times 1 meter.
And that comes out to
4.4 meters per second.
And say you had some
foam packaging that
was 100 millimeters thick.
Then you could say roughly
that the strain rate would
be approximately equal to that
velocity over the thickness, so
4.4 per second over 0.1 meters.
That' would be 44 per second.
So it's somewhere in that range.
Obviously, the thickness
could be a little bit smaller,
it could be bigger.
But it's in that ballpark.
And if you do tests on
servo controlled instrons
or you do a drop
hammer test, you
can get strain rates
in that ballpark.
OK.
So we're talking about
impact and not blast.
OK.
So most of the energy
that's absorbed
is really absorbed in
that stress plateau.
So if you think of the
stress/strain curve,
most of the area under
the stress/strain curve
comes from the area from
underneath the stress plateau.
So the mechanisms of
absorbing the energy
are going to be mechanisms that
are associated with a plateau
stress.
So for elastomeric
foams, we've got
elastic buckling of the cells.
And one of the advantages
or disadvantages-- depending
on what you want-- of this
is that the deformation
is recoverable and you
got to have rebounds.
So if you have an object and you
drop it onto elastomeric foam,
it's going to bounce
around like that.
So the elastic deformation
is going to be recovered,
and you're going to get rebound.
If you have a foam that
has a plastic yield point
or is brittle, then
the deformation
is going to be largely from
dissipating plastic work
or work of fracture.
And in that case,
there's no rebound.
But once you've loaded it,
you've crushed the thing,
and you've permanently deformed
it, and you can't use it again.
So sometimes if you ride
your bicycle like I do,
if you have a helmet, you
should wear your bicycle helmet.
If you have a problem,
if you have an accident,
and your helmet get
smooshed, that's it.
You have to throw
your helmet away.
You can't use it again.
And this is why.
[INAUDIBLE], even
if it doesn't get
smooshed, if you hit your
head at all, [INAUDIBLE].
Exactly.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
You need a new helmet.
Go ahead.
Talk about helmets because I'm
on a helmet conversion thing.
Yes.
You've got to wear your helmet.
And you should change
it every now and then.
Anything else you'd like to add
about bicycle helmet safety?
No, absolutely.
You've got to wear your helmet.
So I know several people who
would have had their head
smooshed had they not
been wearing their helmet.
So you have to wear your helmet.
Let's see.
OK.
If you think about natural
cellular materials, things
like wood, they
often have cell walls
that are fiber compensates.
And you can dissipate energy by
mechanisms related to the fiber
nature, so by things like
fiber pull out fracture.
And then you can also have
open cell foams with fluids.
You can have fluid
within the cells.
And if the cells are open
cells, the fluid effect
is really only going
to be important
if the cells are extremely small
or the fluid is particularly
viscous, or the strain
rates are very high.
So in most cases,
the fluid effects
aren't important
in open cell foams.
But, for example, you could
try to make an open cell
foam that had more energy
absorption by putting
a fluid into it.
So you could put
glycerin into the fluid,
and that would increase how
much energy it would absorb.
Or, you can put
this honey into it.
That would make it
more energy absorption.
And enclosed cell foams,
you may have an effect
of the gas within the cells.
But it's really only
going to be significant
if you have
elastimeric foams where
the cell faces don't rupture.
The cell faces
rupture, then the gas
is just going to
flow out of them,
and that's not going to do much.
So the next step is I
want to go from having
the stress/strain curve
that we've become very
familiar with,
and make something
with that that is a little
easier to see graphically
that shows how much
energy we can absorb.
Remember, what I said what
we're really interested in
is absorbing a certain
amount of energy
without exceeding a
certain peak stress.
So what I'm going to
do is plot another plot
that's based on that.
It's going to be
the energy absorbed.
So w is going to be energy
absorbed per unit volume.
And I'm going to plot that
against the peak stress.
OK.
So we're going to look at
three different regimes here.
We're going to look
at what happens
in the linear elastic part, what
happens in the stress plateau,
and then what happens in
the densification part.
So let's think about the
elastic regime first.
And if I moved up-- say
I moved up to some point
right there where the little x
is on the stress/strain curve.
Then the amount of
energy I absorbed
would just be equal to
this little bit here.
And if I moved up, and then the
peak stress would be this peak
stress there.
We'll call that sigma p1 and w1.
And if I moved up over
here, I'd be at w2.
And that would be
sigma p2, right?
And if I know the modulus, I
know what that relationship is.
And I get a relationship.
And these are going to be-- I'm
going to do this on log scales
here.
There's going to be log,
and that's going to be log.
I'm going to get in that
linear elastic regime.
The energy is going to go as
the peak stress squared over 2
times the modulus of the foam.
Remember, energy is a
half stress times strain.
And I can say strain
is sigma p over e.
So it's 1/2 sigma
p squared over e.
So on my log1 plot
here, this is just
going to be a straight
line like that.
And then I'm going to
get to this value here.
I'm going to get to my
collapse stress here.
So let's call that single star.
And at that point, the
more I go along here,
every point I go
along, like that,
I'm going to absorb
more and more energy.
But the stress isn't
going to go up at all.
So then this thing here is going
to go like that because I'm
absorbing more and more energy.
But the stress just
stays the same.
So this is good news if
we want to absorb energy.
And then once I get to
the densification point,
then it's going to do
the opposite thing.
As I go along here,
at each increment
I'm not absorbing
that much more energy.
But the stress is going up.
So at some point it turns
and starts to look like that.
So this part here corresponds
to linear elasticity.
This bit here corresponds
to the stress plateau.
And this bit here
corresponds to densification.
And the point where
I would like to be
is right here,
because here I'm going
to absorb the most
energy possible
through the peak stress.
So you can think of that as
sort of an optimal point.
And I'm going to refer
to that as a shoulder
because it's the
shoulder between where
the curve bends over again.
So I've only got a
couple minutes left.
But let me just
show you one thing
and then we'll talk about
this more next time.
So I've just done this
for one relative density.
But if you look
at the screen, you
can imagine I would have
stress/strain curves for lots
of different relative densities.
And let's say these are
all at the same temperature
and all at the same strain rate.
And I could draw a curve
that looks like that
for each stress/strain curve.
And if I did that, I'd
get a family of them.
So this is our
energy absorbed here.
I've normalized it by
dividing by the solid modulus.
This is our peak stress here.
And I've normalized that by
dividing by a solid modulus.
And I've got a sort of family
of these things, right?
They all have the same shape.
But they shift depending
on the relative density.
And then the thing
that makes life good is
that these shoulder points
you can connect with a line.
And you can mark off
the relative density
for those shoulder
points on each line.
And then the last
step you can do
is you can just
plot these lines.
And you can repeat this
for different strain rates.
So this would be a family
of these guys here.
There's a family of those lines
at different strain rates.
And then you would join up
the points that correspond
to each relative density.
So you can make a
drawing that looks
like this that summarizes the
most energy you can absorb
for a certain peak
stress for foams
of different relative densities
tested at different strain
rates.
You could do it for different
temperatures if you wanted to.
So next time, we'll
talk about that.
But I'm going to
stop there for today.
OK?
Are we good?